developed our Science and Technology
over one century quantum mechanics was
discovered a hundred years ago and all
of our gadgets are based on that
understanding of quantum mechanics just
100 years that's one part in 100 million
of the age of the universe so most stars
formed five billion years before the Sun
so most likely they are much more
advanced than we are and one thing we
need not to worry about that's something
that's Stephen Hawking argued that we
should be really careful they might harm
us I don't think so I think there's so
much Superior to us it's just like a
biker you know driving down the sidewalk
and what the colony of ants does in the
crack of the pavement is completely
irrelevant so I think we're dealing with
something far beyond us